now that the Senate has spoken in terms
of any punishment to the president he's
impeached forever no matter what he says
or whatever headlines he wants to carry
around
you're impeached forever you're never
getting rid of that scar and history
will always record that you were
impeached for undermining the security
of our country jeopardizing the
integrity of our elections and violating
the Constitution of the United States
our purpose in all of this in addition
to holding him accountable so he stops
doing what he's doing and no future
president thinks that she or he could
have Liberty to take us away from the
republic if you can keep it to a second
Amendment enables me to do whatever I
want no that's not what our Constitution
is about so we will continue to do our
oversight to protect and defend the
Constitution which is three co-equal
branches of government each a check and
balance on the other and some we have
some cases in court now mccann taxes and
that and and that will take time we
didn't need to have that come to a
fruition but that because we had a
strong enough case to impeach and remove
but those cases still exist if there are
others that we see and it's an
opportunity we'll make a judgement at
that time but we have no plans right now
you